okay I think we're good now sorry I
don't know uh sometimes you just gotta
unplug things and plug them back in
hashtag blame Tay which is me anyways
That's Mike he's playing right now Call
of Duty infinite Warfare uh closed beta
that got extended for another day uh
we're gonna be switching off uh checking
out some of the rigs it's actually
working this time because Friday
uh wasn't working at all I apologize for
the no sound earlier and I thank you to
everyone in the chat yelling at me
saying no sound no sound no sound but
now we figured it out see Chad's always
got your bat I'm like yeah they helped
out yeah uh not a lot going on in this
match so far
I think this map is the one that went up
today Precinct no this was up yesterday
got you oh yeah what was the one today
you know uh I do not recall I'm not sure
so right now we're playing TDM but they
added like gun modes so I'm not sure if
maybe domination and some of those other
modes got the different Maps because
from what I played yesterday I didn't
really see
um
new maps I've been playing about the
force five or something or the same ones
gotcha
oh all right actually
I'm playing your profile that was a cool
skin yellow gun yeah yeah we have some
of that too yeah we can do that after
and then today for whatever reason we
got some more keys which will let us
open some more boxes then we got 90
today
which is good that's like three boxes
yeah that's three uncommon boxes
some people are saying no sound
I'm pretty sure there's sound now but I
can't tell if you're trolling me
hopefully you're not trolling me
thank you
if you're still suffering from no sound
try refreshing because everyone else
says it's fine you're gonna type that
because the people who don't have sound
aren't gonna hear that that's true
oh
I like that gun all right bull sharks
I've never used it before so yeah just
make sure you hit it because I've seen
some people whip completely with it it's
embarrassing yeah well it's not it's
probably not the easiest thing to hit
you know I really hope that I unlock
Counter UAV because it's like one of the
best kill shoots I feel like Counter UAV
yeah it's useful
enemy UAV
yeah I get streaky and coffee yeah I
know that feeling
you kind of wish you're in that other
Lobby we were just in huh yeah we went
beyond first yeah we got him first
the sound is too loud how can it be too
loud
all right so right now you're using SMG
I've been using SMGs mainly but there's
a couple good assault rifles as well
yeah well the first one's not that great
the Envy oh man some guy was whooping me
with the Envy but he had a like a
crafted one I think but probably just
stuck with it Maybe
smoked
should I use full charge when I get near
bull rush whatever it was called yeah
it'd be nice if someone on your team
where you got UAV up make it easier to
kind of get that off dang
I don't have the range for that
yeah we got a sniper yeah no I was
talking about him oh okay the uh Steel
Dragon doesn't go that far
well you don't have the Steel Dragon oh
he was here
kind of quick scope I like it yeah it's
kind of tough for this guy I mean I
don't disagree with a lot of people
saying this is like very similar or like
some type of um Advanced Warfare Black
Ops matchup yeah kind of pretty much is
that the Rings are kind of like
Specialists and from like hero shows and
I mean the Specialists had like whoa
they had alternate abilities which is
kind of what this is except I guess
there's three but then there's like
perks too or traits
damn they're like moving together
I just feel like the kill time is like
insanely fast
so you gotta have really good reactions
yeah be pretty decent at COD I guess
that's always been the same yeah
for sure
someone mentioning Ginger the ninja I
think saying they need to let Cod take a
year off I don't think that's gonna
happen nope that's why they have
alternating Studios so that they can
like yeah work on the next one without
really having to like Scrambler yeah
oh
a man that bubble thing is interesting
though it absorbs damage it's actually
good for snipers
um yeah so like if you try to fire it in
the inside the bubble it doesn't do this
oh that's not a lethal grenade is it oh
[__] that guy's Gonna Save you yeah
what's your uh favorite rig out of the
six that are playable
um
I really like uh
the synaptic when you go around on all
fours the dog the dog mode yeah I mean
it's fun uh I don't know I like
I actually like Warfighter the first one
kind of yeah like that with a clock the
crazy AR yeah it's like a um bow Caster
or something
[__]
I'm gonna try that right now
what
what is going on
stairwell
like I was chasing for a while probably
yeah if you guys have questions or
whatnot in the chat I'm monitoring the
chats to the best of my ability uh and
oh that's synaptic yeah holy [__] did he
dogmode you I missed it
yeah
this is the PS4 version we are playing
on PS4 I'm not loving this map
I guess I voted for it so it's kind of
my fault
did you vote for this map this is the
one I like the least I want to say uh
but I got used to it though do you
that's another thing uh with a lot of
the Call of Duty games at least for me
and multiplayer is that
a lot of uh the like the first like the
first day is learning the maps and the
spots and where it's like good to be or
where people spawn at yeah
yeah so far I've only unlocked the
fourth rig I played a lot of synaptic uh
to start and it was pretty fun with a
dual like SMG uh like wrist things or
whatever like his little attachments on
his arms what was he using but uh I
started to use the fourth rig the FTL I
forget yeah FTL and he pretty much has
Golden Gun uh like from Destiny so it's
like a one shot Black Ops 3 or Black Ops
three yeah yeah
who had him in Black Ops three
oh it was the it was the girl with like
the Magnum yeah and then I forget her
name but yeah yeah me too definitely
but I think this one you get more it's
like seven shots or like a timer
people are saying like you should get to
get better I'll try
oh man
I mean it's gonna be interesting time I
mean we're gonna eventually have a chat
about Shooters and
um because there's like three coming out
right like you have this coming out you
have Titanfall 2 coming out you have
Battlefield coming out and with all
those three kind of coming out within
like a couple weeks of each other gears
too not first person but this is the
shooter true
um with all those games coming out like
now like slowly or around the same time
it's gonna be interesting to see like
what people pick because you know a lot
of people don't have enough you know
money to spend on like four or 60 games
or 360 dollar games so
um it'll be interesting to see we'll
have that conversation eventually on the
lobby yeah I've played all three at this
point
um
this in Battlefield more so uh no
actually I play a lot of Titanfall for a
review event recently
um
yeah they're all different in their own
way but they are kind of
there's a lot of Shooters and then you
have like earlier in the years like
OverWatch battleborn Doom uh Doom
OverWatch and doom which I really liked
in fact I thought there were some good
parts to OverWatch or sorry battleborn
yeah I didn't play much though because
overwatching Doom around some people
asking if we like this game uh I've only
played multiplayer uh I think it's fine
I think to me it's like if you like cod
and you have friends that play COD
you're probably gonna play this Cod uh
so it's like that I don't think it's
from what I played of like the maybe
eight or so hours give or take kind of
feels
like slight tweaks to what is existing
so it's just how much do you like hot
that's that's my opinion I don't know
about
um yeah I'm having fun with it for now
the progression I think is if it wasn't
for the progression oh yeah and the
crafting the crafting is cool it's not
as in-depth as I was hoping but it's
it's there's more I like that you can
have like a fashion you're a lot allied
with and then you know there's just a
lot and they give you objectives to do
which is nice like get double kills or
headshots or stuff like that
you are now in the lead I actually like
this map it's kind of cool layout like
this goes up here oh nope I guess I did
not know as well yeah this one yeah yeah
is that kind of crazy though because the
scorcher can get you from it in here
which is kind of insane to think
yeah see the zero gravity doesn't come
in effectively no until you die yeah
yeah it's weird it's just like a
it's just a cool little thing it's like
in Destiny I was hoping they would take
it like use that for the gameplay
so yeah usually if your team's on the
other side they're gonna start spawning
here so it's gonna be like crazy intense
fights oh yeah
I probably shouldn't go that way yeah
that's how you get a lot of slaying
yeah there is crafting in this uh Kyle
James it's not like crazy in depth as
Mike said but you you do get scrap as
you play in like complete um like
missions and then there's also loot
boxes that you can open up with keys
where you hope that you get you know
like a legendary but I I feel like you
can't just use the legendary right you
have to craft up to it I think or at
least unlock the car and then there's
faction specific ones that you get
so I will say I fought against some
people with like the legendary versions
of guns and they're like ridiculous the
gold tier ones yeah or orange whatever
they look like yeah they're pretty
insane um the perks and just all that
hopefully we can find someone that has
one or maybe we'll find one uh someone
killed one killed us with a legendary
last time I thought oh really yeah I
only have uh I think blue tier stuff
right now uh but we're close to being
able to uh craft some purple tier stuff
so you got bull rush try to actually
sound like a map yeah because it's a
straight line down the corridor I'll
come in for the side oh you can't
[__]
yeah I kind of like this gun it's pretty
stable kabar yeah I probably didn't say
it right but yeah I have a the radiant
version of that one which is like the
third tier or the second tier it's
pretty good I like that one that's
probably my assault rifle so far that I
like the most yeah and then SMG is kind
of hard I kind of like the karma or the
um the rpr ego but yeah whoa
all right
yeah they're all on that side now
oh
this would be interesting to see what
the single player for this is like too
so yeah there's no loading screens it's
either cutscenes or like you actually
flying into space oh really that's kind
of cool
apparently it's supposed to be like one
big thing
it could be cool I mean I don't know
last last game Infinity war did was
ghosts
right it's actually weird that a lot of
people that started Infinity Ward are
releasing a game a week before this
Titanfall 2. hmm
spawn entertainment those guys need the
food on them
use that
thank you
you got seven shots yeah we have timer
all right pretty much a one shot one
kill
ER did uh ghost leave a sour taste in
your mouth yeah kind of
I think like a lot of people
um it was
the multiplayer would seem uninspired it
wasn't much new with it they just used
the Pick 10 system they had and um
what was it Black Ops 2 they introduced
that way yeah I believe so
oh damn
poisonous [__] still um don't forget
your bull rush later yeah
he's right there
all right let's just use bulrush I've
never used it so hopefully I don't miss
or anything I think you have some
control of like how it turns but like
you know what I mean like you're still
kind of going forward okay like The Jug
or not you know
[Music]
finish the mission yeah so that's like
your faction alignment and they'll give
you like stuff keys and whatnot for
doing that stuff yeah
enemy Scarab active
also there's zombies for this one I
think this game well eventually I've
played it actually I don't I have no
idea what I'm supposed to talk about or
not okay then you shouldn't talk about
it it's uh I mean I people know what it
is amusement park 80s
if you like that
guy was on the box
friendly drone support is active all
right
drone support is active
I look dumb
just going for a nap you know in the
quarters
what was uh what would you say is your
favorite Call of Duty
um Modern Warfare 2. really yeah I
played I mean the first one's campaign's
really good but I played the second
small player so much I think I prestige
eight times wow okay yeah back when I
could put that much time into one game
though yeah I I liked Modern Warfare 2
but I just felt like with all the kill
streaks it just felt kind of cheap
sometimes like compared to like modern
warfare one I guess I don't know because
like you could get like Harrier with a
chopper and like a chopper Gunner and I
was like all right ooh I like it there
we go all right so that was way quicker
of a damn it I gotta stop reloading so
much yeah luckily that guy was not good
nope that guy's got his uh equalizers
out is what I believe that's called yeah
it's the alternate for synaptic oh [__]
there it is again
I've never used those ones I don't think
I just used the go on all fours dog
thing oh really uh they're pretty good
though because you get both arms and you
get fired like they're they fire pretty
quickly so as long as you have what's
behind me too good move man
um they shred if you can uh
are you dead yeah I got saved by your
buddy damn
uh is it one hit melee no at least not
with liquor melee not with the normal
yeah
there are like throwing knives and stuff
though yeah
I like how you shoot I like how you
shoot it like it's a battlefield but
there's like no recoil in these games
what else I've been playing yeah there's
Battlefield yeah those guns are so tough
to use yeah because you actually have to
burst there's weight to the right see
that you see how it's just like a laser
beam you gotta think that the whole time
yeah this is we're in the future you
know there is no recoil on guns anymore
they're not actually bullets are using
okay so that that's a variant of the
karma uh it's something you craft or I
guess you could technically get in the
Box
I got bull charge again which is nice
damn I think that's the same guys yeah
he's got a Karma commission as well
different names for the guns essentially
there's like three tiers blue purple and
epic or they're I think is this
well there's common yeah there's common
and then there's the blue Terror there's
a purple tear and then there's like a
gold tier yeah yeah it's kind of like uh
that was in Black Ops three too right I
believe no it wasn't I thought there was
like a bow like a special bow and stuff
like that and it was like gold here
um there might be I'm not positive I
never I didn't play
um too much Black Ops 3 no I played a
lot of Black Ops though for some reason
blending with other games I reviewed
that last year okay gotcha I mean like
if anything chat will correct me if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure there were
like like whatever game the battle was
in which I'm pretty sure was Black Ops
3. oh here we go
oh man
almost a dream you're down three
damn
same dude close
you got oh no you guys are winning my
bad I totally read that wrong I thought
you guys were down
took it
foreign
yeah I think you guys are about to lose
here
[Music]
killed in a mess hall sure I'll give it
a go here
there's always going to be uh Cod versus
Battlefield and people that you know
don't like cod or don't like Battlefield
Etc
I get it guys I get it return to base
dang
I didn't uh change my armor stuff too
much
but that's a thing as well right like
you can change some of the gear but yeah
I think it's I forget where you go to do
it here we'll go like open some boxes
and stuff oh we got a rare card
nice
all right let's go
all right so we can open some boxes we
have enough for almost four of them I
think
big money I got an epic actually I just
don't have an unlocked the gun so crappy
all right we got gyps
big money
oh
and this is
got enough for one more
almost enough for two more
oh great yep that's exactly that's
exactly what I wanted no Striker's the
one I like what does Striker do I forget
because that's I remember this
hold on let me equip my unicorn
um I'm magical as [__] yeah baby you
think it's standard or classified
or is it where's my unicorn at
oh there it is yeah magical AF
um okay
you said Striker
well it's we're close
um he's got that crazy gravity like
black hole gun right is that the guy
maybe yeah and then a defensive turret
uh I wish I play I guess I'll play some
you change your HUD if you want
so he's got three payloads which is the
claw which is that crazy AR and then
double Street points
or temporary speed surge
I love the claw about the claw have you
used these before the the like I mean
obviously you have but like um
no not these ones oh wait yeah
persistence I've used
uh that one that's not the best to get
yeah I don't like that yeah because then
it's especially if you're decent if
you'll find a let's find a match
oh I can show them the crafting while
we're at it so
I found that in a box but you know I got
the Butcher on my first ever crazy I
don't have the type 2 unlocked or I
didn't at the time so I gotta go try
that out
yeah
uh I've used wait where is it oh it's
not in here
it's weird
because there's a like gold tier of um
the karma but
it's not
so these are epic yeah like you said in
the legendary and then rare
we are not even close to being able to
craft that we are broke I only have 300
scrap
which makes everything useless
essentially what do you even get scrap
from uh from doing missions and like oh
I got the commission from doing this
okay so I need four more levels and then
we'll get this havoc
oh you get a you got a 25 player kill
streak you get a
the atomizer strike
crazy
all right we found a game
all right
hopefully I can do all right
Tay's showing off his inner Brony I
guess so
what's weird about the uh that assault
rifle the claw or whatever is it like it
doesn't you have to like aim down the
reticle to like get it to like
get the reticle in the middle otherwise
it's like really wide but I guess you
could hip fire it I don't know yeah I
guess so oh no of course it's the this
level the one I don't like the most
uh
Team Deathmatch going with the way what
gun is that Karma yeah ignition
with extended mag because I I'm a scrub
and don't want to reload press left on
the d-pad
oh is that what it is oh I was trying to
figure it out because you can do that in
the windscreen too right yeah okay
emotes
heck yeah I'm guessing you can find
emotes too then
um
I think so
use the parkour stuff a lot in this game
not really I use it more to escape but
um because like every time I wall run I
feel like I just get picked out of the
air when someone's just like standing
there yeah and then it's like what was
the point of wall running if it was none
sniping seems pretty crazy uh if you're
good at it yeah I've seen a lot of
people sniping during this closed beta
found some streaks
like this it's like why would I I guess
I guess I would
throw them off
I screwed that up
I thought I killed that other guy sooner
and then I didn't unfortunately
sure dude or they were
gotta know the spawns man so you can
kind of spawn trap him there should be a
guy right here
oh
that feeling about this
go pick up kick off to clean it up you
know oh that guy's camping that that cat
don't kill him
oh I can't believe that guy lived
this gun's been in ever against the
Marvel for the vector looking yeah the
vector
oh is there a couple people sniping I
think there is oh [__] oh [__]
that guy's trying for those trick shots
uh they're everywhere yeah well that's
like that's what happens man like
they all spawn on top of each other so
it's like you should expect that there's
maybe a crapload of people
okay that guy's going for like those
those hot 360 like no scope in the air
he wants the footage
pretty much I'm here just to get killed
so that you know
people don't yell at us see that guys
see I'm telling you man everyone's
trying to get those sick montages MLG
baby
boy Tony Hawk
I try sniping
oh there's someone chasing me
we're gonna claw it up here hopefully
pop our UAV first
all right
[Music]
I hope I don't lose this I probably will
it's the worst feeling when you have
like your super out and then like you
can't find anyone or you just die before
you can kill him yeah
I think this is better closer they are
all right next to each other yeah
they're sniping too
holy [__] they were they just got
scorched though oh my God what a waste
of a [__] okay
dang it all right everything was going
so well Mike and then I failed there
yeah you're doing better than I was
uh well I played it more and you've been
playing a lot of Battlefield this is so
different like I was playing Destiny
over the weekend and like
um it was just so weird to play this
time you spend like respawning is
non-existent almost just start matching
Square as soon as you die yeah
well it's just this mode though right
we're playing TDM
um I'm sure like kill confirmed or like
mixed games would be different I
actually I really like Call of Duty
games on the hardcore without radar less
health
yeah oh hardcore is like crazy you get
shot twice and you just die yeah I
couldn't do that that's like this the
time to kill in this game is already
like really well
one I just have an SMG
okay
oh no scope oh yeah oh was that a triple
I think so but I got him back with my
grenade
that's the thing like half the time when
like I throw a grenade I'm like man I
wish I didn't throw the grenade because
you're gonna lose a gunfight
but
oh wow
have you seen the claw like grenade
thing that like follows you it's like a
spider I have not it's like a little
Spider-Man that follows you if you're
not like going away
rip oh yeah I know what you're talking
about yeah I actually had the campaign
mission I saw they were using that
ocean okay you can only go in a straight
line
oh crap
they're not close they're a sniper
Scarab is pretty much like us
and get away
he had the nice head glitch
spot on them I want to use my uh super
again but I don't I think we're smashing
them so hard that
might not get the chance
get her off
oh [__]
I thought that was your teammate yeah it
was but they're like behind us somewhere
he knew that's the level that's the last
rig right there
Anthem yeah uh is that Phantom I don't
think Phantom oh yeah yeah you're right
actually Phantom's last one okay right
oh no I only got one kill with it
maybe someone's there
yeah reticle is weird
yeah
yeah see that's a legendary weapon not
an epic but yeah the benediction oh
that's an lmg I don't think I would ever
use an lmg in uh TDM did we get first
yeah left d-pad that
what am I doing why isn't he doing
anything
did I break it brony
it's just left d-pad right yeah is it
because I spam it's different when
you're on the victory screen
all right we'll do one more with uh with
the uh what should we call it all right
2kd we'll take it
um we'll stay in this Lobby because that
seemed all right but there's a lot of
guys going for trick shots so you never
know
um
I'll try another gun though like the uh
this one so this is a rare gun the
game's good radiant yeah
K Bar
this gun seems pretty good too I see a
lot of people use it
um
four grip
get rid of your sniper
you want a snipe later here let me put
that back for you sure
I think people are using the other one
though the first one the longbow
from what I've seen
kind of I like the the new one or the
second one a little better let's see if
oh we have ghosts now hmm
I like that
put that on this guy
which one is
okay
Hardline tracker okay
oh we should uh put a darn wait what are
we gonna do I was gonna put a silencer
to you know really I put that on my uh
really you know assault rifle
yeah go in the car again yeah we'll go
claw again since I didn't really get to
use it
um do you guys like the sounds of the
guns uh I think they're pretty cool I
don't think they're like crazy unique or
anything like that though from the guns
I have used but then again I've been
using a lot of SMGs and stuff so I don't
know what about what do you think like
oh yeah they sound good
wow okay
that's embarrassing nothing uh like
nothing stand out
I mean it not to like yeah keep talking
about it but Battlefield 1 sound is
unreal
so after that I think a lot of things
are gonna just sound pretty average
trying to incite the internet rage right
now yeah
yeah I'll probably play both of these
games a lot actually
I'm excited to see what this campaign's
all about
I think the Widowmaker is pretty good
too
is that the first time
oh [__] oh
no
so the only thing I know that you can do
is run
can't shoot it uh you might be able to
shoot it but I didn't want to turn you
know what I mean yeah I don't think I
would have been fast enough to like turn
to get it yeah
so I like to try to flank here because
usually they would have spawned there as
they did
oh wait you kill both those guys yeah I
did I think so
I don't know did it say double I didn't
see it
I don't think so
Jamie people are still sniping a couple
of them
ah nice spot nice spot
doing the classic uh Camp behind box
still works
I gotta go down the treasures hallway
oh oh [__] he took that off it's not
enough
[Music]
well it's a decent map to snipe actually
because there's a lot of sight lines
there's just like a lot of uh vertical
sight lines so they can kind of just
chill
see that's the problem with like reload
spamming like I do it all the time oh
[__] wow I like do it all the time too
and like
just get punished for it
behind you
oh my god let's get the dream baby six I
don't know that was the that was the
dream right there I didn't want to blow
it I was like
oh look what the [__] Let's Line them up
Baby Let's Line them up what do they do
oh we got a warden we got a UAV
um
oh that's a sniper it's not that's not
quite him on his terms
so the Warren's pretty cool it's just
like a ship that like just Reigns Terror
from above yeah
if I had more confidence in myself I'd
do the Thor system the Thor system's
like insane like just keeps like firing
like artillery or like missiles down
from like a satellite what do you mean
if you have more confidence oh like to
get a score streak they're all chilling
in the back again that's why you're
smoking them
they're all grouping up without what do
you think they are oh they're like right
here
send it send the bombardment oh we gotta
go watch it oh man crap it looks like a
laser artillery up that's one
the roof not letting them get through
yeah it depends if there's a glass or
not oh that's a rocket
no I think it's just uh sniper boy oh
was it it looked like he shot a rocket
launcher right by your face
we got to give that clip to Rob
hopefully we we got that claw action
that hot
like whatever it was I hope so too oh
you had his back damn
Yeah so basically since you know kind of
where people are gonna spawn you just
want to try to get to the spawns yeah
oh see like my guy just spawned on me
yeah
can you play Modern Warfare at all the
remaster yeah I'm kind of curious oh
kind of curious when the um
the multiplayers
me too uh yeah I played the campaign a
lot actually recently I got through like
half of it yeah it's still probably
pretty good right still very good yeah
yeah I did not uh get to all gillied up
I wanted to but
I actually used to beat a lot of Call of
Duties on Veterans which is really
pretty tough I wanted to use a claw
there I guess it was better that I
didn't
back when I was hunting for a cheater
three chivos yeah
dude I can't go that way they're all
sniping me I gotta go around
try to get another hot blank
they all spawn on the other side now
I'm gonna die here
there's a dude right next to you too
yeah
oh what did he kill me with that no
grenade
oh he did dude cause an explosion what
uh okay
I guess you gotta give him something
yeah I guess you gotta oh nice shot
you're on Earth right now but
Nice Shot Nice Shot I want the claw okay
you got it hot rod we got that claw
see there's that guy was using a rocket
bam
would have been sick if he blew up I'll
play one more and then we'll switch back
yeah that's us Brony baby
yeah see like what do you do after this
I'm so used to OverWatch to play the
game I was like well that's gotta be
play a game and show that I wish they
had them
should I play as someone else or should
I Claude again
I'm trying to do two things I'm like
trying to get Rob footage but then
trying to like show some stuff off in
the Stream
switch it up
I haven't really done too much of that
how good is that laser thing is it just
good for Close Quarters no it's I mean
it's you don't have to be accurate to
use it but it's not that powerful it's
more like for suppression and group like
control
it's cool it's worth trying out all
right we'll try it out it seemed like it
was pretty short range though that guy
was trying to shoot it from across the
way and it was not gonna hit me yeah the
the Steel Dragon is you gotta do you
have like even better responses because
if they get the drop on you you're not
gonna kill them
I've seen a few of these people like
playing all day oh yeah like there's
there aren't that many people in the
servers yeah I mean it's closed beta so
not everyone has it right now and you
know like there is one more day to play
right so it makes sense that everyone's
trying to get it in
um
but yeah
all right let's see so I've used the uh
I can try using this gun but it doesn't
have as many bullets because I don't
have extended mag on it yet and it's
like the rate of fire is like super high
so it can kill people how many Red Dot
or anything but uh
we'll see I'm gonna have problems up for
sure
that's basically my way to cop out
and say you know it's your Escape yeah
you get to make some excuses hopefully
no one comes that way
oh I totally missed second grenade hope
someone's there though
yeah he's not gonna win that
some of the guns are cool though cool
though like the e-rad or whatever uh it
reloads on its own
like slowly it adds a bullet like for
oh interesting I dare you yeah you don't
do that
classic classic
Mike
I'm gonna throw a technical grenade in
there or anything wow there are people
everywhere
oh they're behind me
and I got caught reloading
I tend to spam that's why I need the I
need the extended mags man
then I don't have to reload
that guy
no oh yeah I always go for the fast
reload perks yeah this one just pops out
the magazine that or I need extended
mags either one but like
this comes in a greater range there you
go this gun's probably better though FHM
oh that guy's using whatever the burst
gun is
have you used I think is it the rk3 well
I have no idea I didn't know there was a
burst gun yeah there's a burst Gun
there's always a burst gun or Modern
Warfare I just used that M16 yeah dude
that thing shreds I can't believe it's
still like
oh God this is not the map to be using
in SMG I guess
that already got to get up close and
personal
oh hello
let's switch it up
apparently this is an assault rifle the
uh type two oh wait
let's hold triangle
there you go oh
that didn't make it better
let's switch it back it's good it's like
just in terms of fire rate it's better
for like close quarters yeah
it would have been better for that last
map though I feel like yeah definitely
well that's the one I've used it on here
uh the sniper the sniper rifle I use if
I hold triangle it becomes more of like
an automatic rifle oh man what are you
just killing with like a shot oh sniper
oh actually that was the one I was
talking about the Widow yeah or no the
second sniper rifle like becomes just a
assault rifle if you hold triangle dude
we can't go that way
we went from dominating to having
problems oh we killed his uh streak
though
oh wow he sniped me
all right
mmm this one okay oh
oh my God this guy is a pro MLG
I am not good at quick scoping how about
you nope not at all I thought they kind
of like with each game I feel like
they're trying to Nerf it a little more
oh is that I used to do it Michaela oh
C4 that's what that is
oh that guy didn't die
did he shot a rocket you look like yeah
you just put out the personal trophy
system thing
dude there's probably a sniper to that
oh that guy's dead
you're pretty bold about running out
there I know I know that sounds smart I
was playing like way smarter than the
last game
it's another problem in my mind it's
just like I don't know
every time I play Cloud I just want to
like get back into The Fray yeah but
half the time it's a bad idea this guy's
controlling this person scare of like
out in the open
all right
never good to see a comeback
no oh like the actual point to get well
it's just like
still Dragons Ready oh I'm talking about
the best time to pull it out right now
actually they're grouping up you could
oh there's another guy oh there's one
behind me too so I think as long as the
people are in that like big reticle yeah
yeah it'll like chain
no not even chained it just goes
directly from a gun to each person oh my
goodness that guy's really good sniping
that and I'm probably standing still for
him which is making it easier
this is insane what is everything
happening all right guys so close to
dying
that's what a cod is though man it's
like no I'm even like I don't know like
the original Modern Warfare when I
there's so many big Maps there's no more
big Maps
this from okay from the beta there don't
seem to be any big Maps like where you
can snipe and actually kind of like hide
and play it safer yeah but sniper is
pretty quickly
let's kill that kills on you back on a
roll yeah with a gun that I'm actually
using with yeah I was trying to show
some diversity but uh sorry one right
under you yeah yeah unless he jumps out
jump up
oh
it looks like that dude just threw a
throwing star at him
there are throwing knives
you know at some point
like you know how like you camp a spot
and then someone like gets it really
annoyed when they camped on yeah like
that's what I feel like I'm doing to
them right now probably
shine
oh I should have waited that last one
damn it
bombarding I don't know they're gonna
get it I think they might be gone by
this point
yeah I think that was like their spawn
and they had already got another
oh don't aim down sight there
[__] I don't know if I'm gonna get
another Steel Dragon
is
no probably not there's seven six kills
away
is that how it goes oh that's uh Striker
six kills away from them I didn't match
yeah yeah yeah rack oh man this is tight
they caught up I thought we were losing
this whole time nope that's speeding so
hard
yeah they're about to win no that guy
just sent me
all right here you go sir sorry if it's
a little sweaty
uh see if you can steal Dragon it a
little bit I almost had a it was almost
a good situation but then um
yeah they just showed up behind me oh
there's a striker right there
don't be that guy don't do it nah
sometimes you gotta you gotta Camp a
little bit because like it's just as
frustrating for the I think that's what
you mean sometimes it's as frustrating
as the person that keeps dying because
they keep wanting to come kill you and
as long as you move angles within that
room
in these names why not
have we seen Frost yet I don't think so
who no we haven't played yeah yeah we
haven't played frost on stream yet so I
think that r3k is the is the burst gun
okay I'll try that and then the e-rad
that uh SMG is the one that it auto
reloads as you're just running around
it's not like really fast but it's like
pretty it's like okay I got a bull got a
bullet got a bowl what kind of thing
yeah Frontier baby everyone loves
Frontier
you're one key away from another box
use an assault rifle I did use an
assault rifle towards the end there the
the kabar or whatever the K bar is uh so
we have their missions right now
we're in 10 medals
oh
I like this map it's actually pretty
good but then I did really shitty on
probably a good map for um the Steel
Dragon is my guess
I think we might be able to uh did we
just hit 21 I think so yeah
we'll see
two more levels
are using the R Keith rk3 or whatever
yeah should have crafted maybe like one
tier higher yeah whatever it's fine
but an easy way to give myself an
advantage
just remember when you're shooting it is
that burst yeah
I mean what that perk to like increase
the rate of fire oh Jesus
so yeah they're probably all in that to
your right oh that guy's just waiting no
he's smart he doesn't want to have the
flank happen like last game he's still
there I know
uh yeah your whole team is flanking now
though
man this is not as like
accurate as I thought or I'm not
Executives I thought it'd be but it's
not as precise I thought it would be uh
yeah I mean it's tough uh Raphael is
asking or Raphael our Renta so ask me
how do you like guys like the game so
far
I think it's it's fine for a Cod game I
I mean I still enjoyed the the moment to
moment yeah so they figured it out now
they're not
I don't think it's the same yeah this
guy is chilling
they're all prone in the the mess hall
that's a that's a modern warfare one
thing yep
damn that's the guy that's the guy
that's uh was killing me last game for
longbow
let's go there's a lot of two SMGs
everybody's sniping today what is this
uh no man sniping seems to be a meta uh
for some reason
there's a lot of snipers when I was
playing yesterday too just because you
saw what that guy could do right it's
like one shot one kill and like quick
Scopes yeah and with these kind of sight
lines in these hallways it's like all
right well there's not too much movement
they're gonna do
no I'm not going up there again
from my mistake
that would have been better oh [__] oh
[__] he sucks uh I was trying to give
you the benefit of the doubt that maybe
you would have enough time to keep
juking him and like
uh he would keep missing almost I hate
not having a faster reload
okay be honest guys are you enjoying the
game like I said I enjoyed the moment
the moment and I think I enjoy the the
speed of the game uh it is kind of like
a Cod rehash there isn't too much
Innovation that's going on other than
you know some of the crafting stuff
that's not in the game [__] and then uh
some of the some of like the the
abilities of the rigs other than that
I think like we said I think we both
agree that it's fine right
the rig seems sort of glorified
um like not as in-depth as I thought
they'd be I don't know it's it's like
the Specialists on crack a little bit
like from Black Ops 3 if you played that
it's a they're a little deeper than that
because they have alternate it's if you
just
um
Black Ops 3 each Specialists had that
one weapon or that ability this one has
three possible perks yeah two abilities
please
friendly drone supporters act yeah
I always find it hilarious reading these
comments from people that think that we
can't say anything negative because
we're paid off to not say anything
negative I find that hilarious it's like
when Mike gives I would rather play
Battlefield right now yeah I I well I
don't since I don't wow that's crazy
actually in this on this map yeah I
don't care for uh there's one more
Battlefield myself but I could totally
understand why you would rather play
Battlefield in this because at least
there's like some layers there that
might be different yeah you know like
there's Vehicles there's all that stuff
whereas you know granted we're only
playing tem right now but like
domination stuff's like not that
different yeah I got you
hmm
[__] whoa
someone just tried to snipe me what was
it I looked like it
I feel like their whole team is sniping
almost yeah
damn that dude surprise
the Widow what am I what are we looking
like on I don't know this yeah
um would you guys agree that Black Ops 3
Beto was better
um
I like the maps in that more they were
bigger these maps are not impressing me
at all that's for sure they were bigger
well I like this one this is cool but I
got I need bigger Maps like yeah that's
the kind of here we go and I think that
the whole ability thing that was the
first time they they showed it in a Cod
game right if I'm correct on that
statement so that was kind of cool like
having sparrow with a bow and arrow and
then uh it was Barrel right I'm pretty
sure hopefully I'm wrong and she also
had sonar pulse yeah [__] all right so
oh you really want to do it
get one more let's get into business
Main Street yeah it's like
Mike got roasted for giving Dark Souls
three and eight I think an eight was
fine for Dark Souls I mean
but the part of it too is like with the
knee with how the Gamespot review system
works too it's like everything's a whole
point right so you can't give half a
point so like it could have been an 8.5
if we had it at 0.5 but there you know
that doesn't exist so
um
and I think to to your credit too it's
like Dark Souls 3
it was a great game it was fun you know
but it wasn't it's probably gonna be one
of my games of the year just yeah it
just wasn't that different right like
it's still part of the same formula with
some tweaks and stuff like that so like
a lot of Boss later in the game weren't
that was impressive there are a few like
there were bus late in the game I liked
a lot but
um there were too many that felt just
like rehashes of the earlier ones
hot cheese saying play bf1 instead of
this trash well we played a bunch of bf1
you guys did a live stream yesterday of
uh the full multiplayer because we have
that uh and then we also did uh Early
Access last week I'm sure I wouldn't be
shocked if we did maybe another uh live
stream of Battlefield sometime this week
but of course we want to give
um some time to you know show you guys
Cod infinite Warfare uh close beta uh
you know so you guys can check that out
and you know determine if you like it or
not I'm feeling disco way more than any
other yeah
oh damn nail biter
yeah that gun's really good the karma
and I I was able to steal the Epic
version from someone one time and it was
like oh okay this is like really good
bam quick scope
and then pistol oh that guy would have
got a triple I think
uh Hudson flat saying any idea if they
plan on opening the beta at some point I
mean maybe I like it wouldn't shock me
they did for Black Ops right yeah I
believe so it's like I want to say it
was like maybe a week after or something
oh you can open a crate
um and the game's like coming out soon
so I think if they were gonna do an open
Beta hopefully they'll do sooner than
later
oh man not even uh just a a human ripped
open yeah we have that one already it's
called autopsy
I guess it's a human that's been like
infected by an alien or something okay
yeah
uh Isaac Austin saying I don't
personally like how slow Battlefield 1
plays I mean that is one of the
differences like main differences I
guess between these two kind of games is
like this is like frantic fast-paced
action whereas Battlefield you can argue
like there's more strategic stuff kind
of going on
um you know there's the map's way bigger
there's Vehicles there's all these added
layers to that game so it is slower by
virtue of just like how that gameplay
Works compared to this let's do this
really quick do it you got like all of
seven seconds or something
no that neither of those would have gave
you reload unfortunately one was just
ads faster kind of like level nine in my
game oh really yeah I thought you said
you didn't like the first assault rifle
don't love it but it's I mean well no
sorry I meant it's not that like as cool
as some of them it's like yeah it's just
like yeah your basic assault it's
actually not as much yeah it just looks
like an M4 right now
uh Nathan saying card isn't that that
fast pace though Titan Falls on another
level Cod is this weird Middle Ground I
don't think that I think Titanfall like
at least from what I remember when I
played that I think Alpha like the time
to kill him that is like slower than
this in my opinion I don't know about
how you feel about that um
too I can't talk about it yet though
yeah
well from my from me playing Alpha I
feel like this game is
well time to death is definitely faster
I don't know if you're talking about
movement mechanics but
title 2 is a little more measured in
moving around than anything
oh it's the same guy man
he's using the basic Longbow too yup are
you sure yeah it's the great one uh I
don't know maybe it's just everyone's
using the basic Longbow I don't know
yeah
someone else saying uh KO wing also
saying TF is slower than Cod
I don't know because you have to also
factor in that the TitanFall 2 like
those maps are like way bigger than
these Cod maps at least the ones we're
playing on so far so like the distance
to travel from one side to the other is
like I think that is yours I also just
use my FTL jump oh nice
they increase the movement speed of
being TF2 yeah I'm sure they did
um but yeah
nice
yeah I have to I have uh Warden on your
team I have a faster reload like variant
of this gun and I also have that
um attachment to let you reload faster
so it just he just pops out the magazine
and then just swaps into it really fast
oh [__] dude
I have no idea
nice head shot oh they're all spawning
there all right
TL
well they're all over here uh PS4 Fanboy
saying do you think the dislikes on COD
videos will have an impact on sales I
don't think it will I mean like I feel
like if you've been playing Cod you're
probably gonna buy another Cod
um and if you haven't then I don't think
the dislikes are gonna affect that I
think in general like cod videos just
tend to get a lot of dislikes because
people just want to go on there and hit
a dislike just because it's Cod
oh what's this thing
uh the Maller lmg
all right let's try it out so what do
your boosters do here like higher jump
or something
am I what your special that you have
there it's a f it's a tour oh is it like
warped forward yeah it's not um the
glitch from three it's you go for
someone does have a glitch though
synapsis synaptic or synapse no they hit
yeah it says rewind it says rewind on
the third ability oh okay gotcha cool
shot you in them that was Rob's favorite
actually was that glitch in the shotgun
combo yeah he'd love to glitch back on
them
is that the variant or is that the idea
okay
that looks like it Scopes way slower
than the uh yeah that's why I was using
the other one
or is this the that's the second one the
Longbow is like oh [__] wait what
did I pick up two of them
[__] amateur
Longbow this isn't Destiny yeah the
Longbow synthesis [__] oh get gravity
bald
black hole that's like zarya
oh yeah it definitely is nothing like
something day one Noobs
sorry so is FTL the one that you said to
teleport you for right so it closes
distance sooner probably get for a
shotgun yeah yeah kind of like uh
there's a there's a Titan and um just
Titan that warps and uh title too Ronin
sword in the shotgun
and you can you can get this ability
that adds an extra Dash to your basic
Titan Dash so you have three dashes and
then the warp
oh [__] I couldn't tell which one was
a lot coming that way oh he was ready if
you tried
I guess that one comes up pretty quickly
so that's good I mean as it should it's
not as like game changing I guess it's
like oh he's trying to make plays
the wall plays equals you die
[__]
what if he was like you're in his spot
Maybe
I guess I kind of just assumed ownership
electric Blaze 997 says bet you MW uh
end up One servers will be busier than
uh infinite Warfare I wouldn't be
shocked by that to be honest I think
there's a big Nostalgia feeling for mono
Warfare and a lot of people played
Modern Warfare so
um interesting timing for sure for both
to be out at the same time
um
because some people want that old school
like you know not jumping around
like peer shooter in a way yeah
like I know some friends that are like
they've played a bunch of mdub and
they'll probably you know they're
looking forward to that more than this
for sure
but you know you have to buy this to get
that so do you think
I would not be shocked if they did I
think that
um
I think uh it'll take a couple months
though I wouldn't be shocked if it's
like you know Christmas or like early
next year you know it's probably to help
you know
I hate to say it was probably like one
of those things that they need to use to
help um
boost uh pre-orders or whatever yeah
sucks though because I'm actually
curious what would have happened if they
released both and if like more people
would have just bought yeah Modern
Warfare for like on its own for 30 bucks
I bet they would have
maybe not more I think like to us we
know the vast majority of people to buy
Call of Duty you're just gonna get them
are going to like yeah but I just it
would have
potentially stopped some people from
buying this right yeah potentially so
yeah instead whoa you buy both of them
look at that gnarly scope
getting into a instaprone like the old
days are you good at that no instaprone
I used to be better
but I don't claw some people play like
club or whatever it's easier oh you got
a second nice good work man the Brony
like uh people do the claw for like Mega
Man games too
for the uh jumping and shooting we are
half a level away from Striker
do some of that and probably wrap up the
stream but um you guys have questions or
anything like that feel free to ask and
we'll try to do the best uh that we can
to answer them or just give your
opinions and I'll read some of them the
ones that aren't too trolley and too
hateful because yeah
there's a lot of hate for COD
also if you haven't already if you're a
new viewer or whatnot you know please
subscribe to the YouTube for all our
other live streams we do a couple a week
um as well as some of our other like
content that we make throughout the week
I can also uh follow us on Twitch and if
you're already uh on the Game Spot
awesome
uh gun game is in we'd have to back out
to get gun game but gun game is in uh I
have not tested uh to see a Precinct the
map was in
um we can try doing some gun game in a
little bit see how that goes I guess gun
games like uh like the Cod thing right
where like as you get kills you switch
guns yeah
yeah and try that
um Gears of War 4 has this really good
mode
um arms race it's uh you all start
there's like a set rotation of guns so
you can tell and whoever gets through
the last round like whoever you end with
a boltock pistol and whoever gets the
kills with that
wins so you can tell how close their
team is to winning base and what guns
they're all using nice
uh Jugger boy and L asking us uh what
your favorite gun so far is from the
Veda I'll let you go first
um
I actually like the sniper rifle too
much EBR switch it to assault rifle mode
sniper rifle I'm sorry if I said okay
sorry what was your favorite gun this
one okay
uh mine's probably the kabar or the
karma
uh also Johnny Five I'm not calling
people trolls because they disagree with
me I'm talking about all the people that
like come in to say like oh this is a
trash game play Battlefield one like to
me that's like trolling
a bit because
I feel like you're just saying that to
say that
I think he's trying oh [__] patrolling
you right now by saying that yeah
probably gave him a mini shot out there
I don't mind giving many shout outs to
people that's part of what makes life
feeling fun oh [__] I forgot I'm
synaptic now
oh see and then he said something really
vulgar and then he got blocked
[__] uh yeah Yusuf Mayo saying arms
racing gears is pretty awesome
if I had secret Intel I definitely
wouldn't be giving it away
so for PS4 Fanboy asking sorry
you're probably gonna come from your
right yeah that's right
thanks to Ryan Schubert AKA amble one
for
monitoring the chat
you guys are
being pretty good today I like it
there's a couple there's been a couple
people
you know who you are that you may or may
not have been timed out or banned
um but yeah for the most part everyone
else has been pretty good
and I'm willing to like I said interact
with those people that are uh
humanit classy or at least moderately
classic
[__] I forgot I had this
do
foreign
inside
oh you're going with the um
melee variant if he runs like a dog did
you know you can turn on thermal
what do you mean uh when you get it
later hit Square it'll turn everything
thermal oh cool um it'll make like the
screen blue and then I think all the bad
guys are yellow okay
that guy's trying to akimbo it with
something nice you got a bombardment but
watch out that guy
like just hide in the corner
okay
this is the one I actually been using a
lot like I said it's just not as like oh
my God all right all right oh man you're
so close to the warden wait what just
happened you got to pick the spots on
the map yeah
oh it would have been great if you still
had UAV
that's it yeah
show that off oh man you got two or
three
nice
triple
[__] [__] oh it's on behind you all
right doing work though yeah I mean the
the the first assault rifle in every CoD
game is always like solid yeah
yeah gotta have that one kick start oh
that was a dude I thought that was or
you just do the typical thing where even
if people are ahead of you you just
steal their guns because they're
probably good yeah
I saw you
jerk nice damn cool thing I had nothing
else I could do all right let's use
Reaper
go this way
another question what weapon do you want
infinite Warfare to bring back from the
classic weapon list they probably won't
bring any classic guns back you'll feel
like you have some guns that are similar
to some of the old stuff probably but I
don't think they're gonna bring anything
back
uh if I had my wish I don't know man I
really like the fal back in the day yeah
and then you just add that one perk to
let you full auto
uh and you're saying M16 right for you
one of your favorite guns it's like it
was overpowered as hell but no recoil
you're just playing
kill well not one hit it's like one
burst yeah
I was just talking about burst and I
forgot this gun was Full Auto
oh you have your special yeah
trying to wait what do they call it in
this game because Peter hated it when I
called it that
um
because he doesn't want entitled to it's
your core ability I think that's what we
were talking about
we can look it up after this match all
right here you go see you can press
square yeah now you know he's
like oh it's only sniped him
oh he's doing it too uh no he just
happens to be the same thing as you and
you can't catch up to save your life
because you're not that fast of a robot
dog yeah we only got one
oh [__]
[__] it's all right
you didn't die it could have been worse
positive
I wish
sheep
you always gotta find the the bright
side
P90 is life yeah P90 was legit
okay 90 was legit
uh-oh High CPU usage why
that means we're droppings
[__] thank you oh [__] oh [__] [__]
I had the drop on him he's in the Maller
are you mauling people I think oh behind
you
to him
bring back the awp
the ACR yeah ACR 90.
I like that gun
uh that's a long name to say af-182 love
23.85 hello
hopefully you get strike right now
the um
the UMP
I just always associate the UMP with the
csump and it wasn't that good back in
the day it's like better now
Frank rantz please don't advertise your
channel and our Channel
not very courteous
I'll just get rid of you myself
how do I do it oh I think someone else
timed him out thanks
oh we still didn't get Striker
um we're close come on oh there's
Precinct wait that's not no that's not
the one okay that's not new
someone okay
oh the scar yeah the scar the scar was
legit yeah scar was legit I like the
intervention sniper rifle
from two actually two I think had some
of the best maps too according to rb5
network I look like the Asian dude off
of Lost
I cannot confirm or deny that
fortunately
oh yeah better make your gun now
you can add a third perk you just gotta
ditch the sniper probably yeah
Sandos
oh you want to mute that guy
got him
oh I should have switched to uh silver
Cobra Elite pretty much says
intervention yes
yeah the game the game was good yeah
it looks like Transformers in God that
one guy could be
someone said it looked like chappie
uh Avengers FTW says uh just got here
are there any space-based Arenas this
one uh well this one's in space but it's
yeah you're in the spaceship or whatever
so I'm not really
nice work got warmed up huh grab me says
my friend
uh I'll try to invite you after Ellen
looks like you found your gun huh
so
suppressors in this game are so weird
there's like these Square things on the
end
she's graders
sometimes you got gray some cheese with
your assault rifle
oh what the hell is that oh he's using
sniper he didn't have that quick scope
like those other guys
these are amateurs oh [__] oh yeah yeah
I never saw what cup got him
[Music]
I gotta doing work
4-0 saying how can you like cod 4 for
example and like this at the same time I
think because the shooting mechanics are
like still the same it's just like
movement and the all the abilities that
are different
I mean the core game is still pretty
similar right doing that here
do you platform
keep going oh [__] I don't have a
secondary you don't need to you got 31
bullets
where'd he go
I don't know they're gonna start coming
from there I think
oh
what was he using you read oh no the
type 2 or whatever
there's one behind in the hallway
I'm not gonna deal with that
yeah MW2 maps are pretty good they were
really good
I agree with that
Favela was a yeah and uh
but the only thing I didn't like in MW2
was the fact that like my friend could
just like move to all day
like one-man Army and just like yeah
hang out and uh what was that one with
the uh with the airplane in the middle
the first one in Modern Warfare two
wasn't it two
I'm chasing me for sure
um there's a big airplane in the middle
it's like warehousey and like one of the
warehouses he would just Camp up top put
double Claymore down and just move twos
the whole game and you couldn't do
anything about it
all right
oh you are crazy
okay they clear that snipers
[Music]
chappie run
oh
what
did you hit R1 instead of R2 no I
pressed R2 okay yesterday I hit R1 a
bunch of times instead of R2 on accident
and I was like why didn't I swing I was
like oh right I like that guy's name FX
ctck ghost 420 MLG
that exemplifies the chat I think
no Afghan definitely had a plane uh but
there's another one that was like more
Warehouse in scrap yard yeah scrap yard
pretty sure that was thumbed up too
I don't remember
pretty sure
oh line them up
what is that dude
yeah shred we got uad
yeah that Brony called it in oh dude
they're like all over there you're right
sorry for Backseat game it just happens
it's the suppressor that makes me better
it's like Yeah because it makes it even
more stable right well you can and it's
quiet and they don't see you on the yeah
it's a mini map probably
[__] I gotta stop reloading that's why I
gotta do the use those use those yeah I
used to have mechanics the uh maneuver
mechanics oh there's all over
this is probably one of the smaller Maps
uh first Striker have you used Strikers
uh like ability yeah I kind of forgot
how to work I know like I've used him
when I went to the Call of Duty XP event
I'm just curious like how often the uh
how many shots you get with the uh
gravity's gun thing
oh nice destroyed some equipment that's
always good get those points
oh oh you might if you're super lucky be
able to get your ability again but it's
gonna take some some killing yeah some
killing maybe calling in your your UAV
nice you got it now
[__] no [__] I [__] that up I thought
that was my dude yeah it's all good we
still have it
they're at least good about it where
like if you use it and uh
do I started in Modern Warfare two yeah
there we go maybe we got Striker he's a
strike
stop and start on that break up these
files
oh you got second here we'll do the left
there you go salute
you can only do it once
[Music]
thanks the game's over already
controller's telling me we lost UAV all
right we got Striker
with the gravity Vortex gun and we got
Salvage
uh so we got a lot of Salvage oh here's
the thing
I don't think it's as crazy as that
makes it the same uh from what I've seen
you don't get suctioned like that that's
for sure
yeah zarya is my favorite character in
OverWatch and I feel like I'm gonna like
playing Striker
all right so he's got the gravity Vortex
gun which is cool
uh micro turret oh wow
seems kind of cheap
this guy seems kind of cool get relay
ah that seems kind of meh
okay the trophy
so I guess you have to be this person to
get the trophy
this guy's all about the equipment is
what it is one extra piece of equipment
all right
wait what's this other
item besides the gravity gun
s
um one was the trophy I think right or
was that was I looking at perks by that
point sure
crap can I try to skim through those and
you forgot myself
all right let's uh I just want to see
the gravity gun
I hope it's more than one shot because I
feel like if it's only one shot and you
mess up it's like well
we're not using that ability for a while
and I don't even know if this is the
best map for it I feel like that last
map probably was better
if you pull that off
oh they fall off okay oh he didn't that
was an epic
oh that guy yeah three three seven lucky
one so we should go steal it
talk about in this city
if he dies he's not he's killing
everyone oh he's right there huh no he's
got the okay he's got the e-red all
right the cerebus it'll be over there we
just gotta get over there and steal it
self
uh or he can just kill me again with it
that's him
is it
I don't think it is no nevermind
what do you have
cheering coming from the baseball field
maybe I don't know maybe this is a new
spectator sport
friendly transport is active
where did go Mike
oh God am I chasing one guy
another bunch in that building here
right
gotta bait that guy
oh that guy's dead
I'm not going in that room it's a trap
dude we've circled the whole map
oh
we're looking nearby okay
no I'm throwing grenades
I think that was
that was the guy for sure
oh great they got you again
where is that dude oh he's Vanishing the
finer
it's probably just gonna kill me and
then we're going to be like there you go
[Music]
that was him right there see the last
guy that showed up no you killed you
killed him I did yeah oh you're looking
at the name yeah
okay we got gravity
I wonder
I feel like we should just use it I
wonder if you have to pull it out before
you shoot you know I mean all right yeah
I got two shots
oh one opportunity no no don't count
that no
no dang it
now please learn to aim
you may want to intervene
enemy UAV tell me if you see it on the
ground I'm not like really paying
attention but
it's one of those guys spawn here right
wow I'm awful
you hit him quite a few times yeah
oh he's got the Epic or a legendary of
the md4 the ones like oh crap
I have that too
it's always that guy man
I want your gun
uh die are you serious
oh man you're screwed
he had no idea
bro
yeah nope
I'll clean up
okay no do the slide I always try to
slide and then I just end up kneeling
[Music]
oh I tried Mike I tried
try to bring out the young man young man
playing ability
oh hello oh that guy just walked right
in front of me
oh we got no UAV I almost have gravity
gun which would be sick right now
[Music]
oh there it is
all right we got it we got we got the
Epic weapons
doesn't feel that different so far
I don't like that we have no UAV
course
all right screw it
where they at Mike
oh you can kill yourself yeah
never done it oh man I was trying to
like go to the next area to like get
more people
yeah right there would have been good
thanks Mike thanks thanks for the advice
now
20 bullets funny right
right damn
oh come on
[Music]
all right we did it
no thanks to my really shitty gravity
gun all right let me try one more time
all right I want the gravity gun
I didn't know that you could oh man
that's another play oh did you get
double here all right I think he died
how much longer we're streaming oh I
would do one more match with the gravity
gun called a wrap after that
oh we got first though
what does he do
what is that
uh
yeah 1.43
should we do frost or what map would be
better defrost Frost oh no the gravity
gun Frontier that's the hallways one oh
you're right okay yeah yeah we want that
okay so let's go look back at what okay
so he has that he has the turret
and he has the Centurion which is like a
that destroys projectiles it's probably
good for like what domination
um because he just put that on the point
right destroys projectiles what because
it's like a huge bubble I would assume
yeah or sniping I guess oh wait we'd
never get this level 52 and level 45
we're never getting those I think the
cap uh right now is 30.
what do we get what do we get all right
Frontier your favorite map slash my
favorite map
yeah this one's good I like this map I
do too curious how
Striker handles it
they got three War Fighters
all right let's go
Carmen
team death match
is that always this
and you could change it oh come on I
forget where
cha
KO Wing saying uh hopefully TF doesn't
because a lot like TF uh one I hope so
too but you never know this is a real
bad boy okay
didn't get punished
I think he saw my propulsion nope
two sure who do you go first oh the
three
oh you're right I was thinking that in
my head who do I kill first
usually yeah
that's why I hesitated to shoot a little
bit because it gives it gives you away
yeah
what was that leveled up or something
it's really loud noise oh yeah you got
level 24.
there's a guy sniping down here which is
kind of a problem
I got him don't worry it only took uh oh
wait what
dude give me bullets back
what it should be like right here
I'm hitting that late day whoa
is that coffee even Call of Duty isn't
keeping me awake
uh yeah maybe get coffee afterward yeah
that water is not gonna do you any good
no
oh staying hydrated in the [__] would
you ever do what you just did I don't
know what I'm gonna play tonight maybe
Battlefield
I don't know like oh I'm kind of in the
middle of a review sort of but okay we
can't talk about no it's we could talk
it's Titanfall but there was an event
and then
the review Embark was Monday
so I played a lot of Titanfall too with
Rob uh we had Friday we have some
previous multiplayer preview stuff going
up
from after having spent like 12 hours of
multiplayer
um
I'm looking forward to it you guys both
were totally into it
um yeah I can't really
talk about my opinion yet but
I got an opinion on it nice nice soon
enough right
Monday I think it's the Embargo I'm not
sure if we're gonna get upright at
launch because server potentially
although we are playing for the review
event we're playing on public servers oh
yeah so
keep it up
oh yeah
Vortex gun I wish I had uavs
oh
cryo thing or something there we go
should I just do it do I just let it rip
yeah always makes me nervous to use it
[Music]
I think the lineup like last time
get him
dude that the little intro thing that it
played last time was like way crazier
than that
I just watched that one real bad
I think I'll get it oh wow he had his uh
things out
I think I'll get another thing sometime
gravity gun
uh before a hundred yeah you could you
do pretty I mean like obviously the
better you do
the more you know
everyone's trying this night at least
there anything you could say as you
slide into a room firing a weapon
[Music]
um
yeah you're right they're behind
is a really bad idea
oh I didn't slide [__] yeah you have to
hold it
I think it's momentum based too though
kind of wish you didn't have to hold X
to do the double jump thrust thing
oh you're having to throw a grenade
there
trying to make some big moves
uh I don't think you're gonna get
yeah you're smoking the other team
though
you could if you get like three more
kills right now
or token
dude I think I need more than three
kills
nice
oh got it do it do it one more time
shoot it
no Mike
I slayed I slayed to get this stupid
gravity gun
oh man
I have these camos too God
that's definitely us
all right Mike we didn't get to show off
the gravity gun other than that one time
where I killed myself which is glorious
oops that's the wrong one
there you go it's like I hit a
transition but I didn't uh 24. that's
noted by that screaming guitar chords
halfway through the match yeah man
uh but yeah that was a look at Call of
Duty
infinite Warfare closed beta
unfortunately there wasn't we didn't
have the last rig but um that's uh five
of the six
and yeah thanks Mike for tuning Our
plane and commentating today thanks for
having me and everyone that was watching
and asking questions and or chatting
with us we appreciate it again you can
hit subscribe and like and follow and
all that fun Jazz but uh until next time
uh
uh I guess tomorrow we got the lobby
I'll just try to pimp the other stuff
that we got the lobby we have the lots
of time on the lobby Battlefield we can
talk about
um there's the beta uh Mafia 3 review
which we haven't like actually talked
about yet since we got the score
um
yeah yeah there's a lot yeah there's
probably some other topics yeah welcome
back there's some people asking for you
back after the the Jay hey
but uh
yeah I'm sure like I said we'll probably
have like a battlefield one stream again
sometime at uh this week I'm sure
there's some other stuff we're gonna
have live streaming so stay tuned uh
appreciate it thank you everyone and
yeah see you guys later uh shout out to
Corey bye
thank you